There's a lot to remember
when using the terminal.
You can't just click around and
explore menus like you can
with a graphical program.
This doesn't mean that you need
to remember every command and
every option though.
Looking things up is a regular part
of the terminal user's workflow.
In fact, it's normal to forget
the details of commands you don't
use frequently.
Cowsay is an example of a program
with a bunch of options.
By default, cowsay draws a cow,
but you can customize it too.
For example, by using the -e argument,
we can replace its eyes with carets.
We can also draw a penguin
instead of a cow.
So, how do we keep up
with all these options?
Fortunately, all common shell
programs come with a manual,
and there's a command that makes
it easy to read them, man.
Manual entries are called man pages,
and this is cowsay's man page.
Man pages follow a common format.
The first section includes
the command's name and
a brief description of the command.
The next section is the synopsis.
The synopsis explains how to use
the command's flags and arguments.
Options surrounded by square
brackets are optional.
In this case,
all of cowsay's options are optional.
Some options require
additional information.
For example, if you use the -e flag,
you also need to supply an eye_string.
The description describes all
of the options in detail.
Man pages vary in how they
present this information.
Some man pages alphabetize their option,
while cowsay's man page
is a bit less organized.
You can use the arrow keys to
scroll up and down the man page.
The later sections of the man page
include more detailed information about
the command.
Man pages are typically arranged so
that the most important
details are near the top.
When you're done referencing the manual,
you can press q to exit.